mr. Darwin sir it is time to write your
book my title will be on the origin of
species are you am i funny enough I just
played Charles Darwin yes yes all of
nature is a battlefield remind me where
i read that clear evidence of
transformation over millions of years
the almighty can no longer claim to have
offered every species in under a week
you've killed God's so you're a Darwin
is playing a creation no that's that's
that's rather there's a movie we can
believe in God Bobby doesn't believe in
you either have incredibly different
audiences and one movie is a pure
entertainment and one movie isn't so the
movie about Charles Darwin is an Emma
Darwin who's played by my real life
white it's is a you know a serious movie
about a biopic about a very difficult
time in that his life and their marriage
and Legion is a supernatural action
movie thriller and I play the Archangel
Michael and God has lost faith in
mankind and i haven't sold one coming
down to earth to save the last few
hopefuls send you Gabriel you're always
eager to please unlike you
you